céline gilbert spécialiste des maladies
infectieuses c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir célina
gownder merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france depuis new york on a vu
évidemment tous ces images terribles de
la ville américaine avec ses camions
frigorifiques en guise de morgue telle
est la situation sur place
je suis de new york
et effectivement les hôpitaux sont
submergés cette semaine au cours des
derniers jours la situation était
meilleure mais comme vous avez pu le
voir à la télévision
nous avons des images d'un des hôpitaux
du queens un quartier où l'on trouve
beaucoup outils grandes personnes qui
n'ont pas d'assurance santé car elle
n'est pas universel aux états unis
beaucoup de personnes également à la ba
qui travaillent qui ont des emplois
qu'on qualifierait est essentiel d
emploi par exemple dans le secteur du
service des soins de la santé et des
transports
il ya tant les magasins ce sont ces
personnes qui tombent malades et qui se
retrouve à l'hôpital
ces personnes ton particulièrement
malades en raison de leur fragilité
c'est ce que nous vous nous expliquer ce
soir on avait mis d'ailleurs en exergue
le fait que les afro-américains été plus
touchés que les autres
plusieurs raisons à cela
par exemple il ya des raisons socio
économique c'est à dire que ils ont un
certain d'emplois qu'il ne leur permet
pas de faire du télétravail
ils sont donc plus vulnérables et sont
donc plus susceptibles d'être contaminés
n'ont pas d'autre solution que d'aller
travailler pour payer leur loyer et pour
nourrir leur famille
dans cette population est également loin
de personnes qui ont une couverture de
santé
il est donc très difficile pour ces
personnes d'avoir
c'est aux soins de plus sa population on
trouve beaucoup de comorbidité telles
que des maladies cardiovasculaires le
diabète ou des maladies cardiaques
cela représente encore le risque de
développer une forme sévère du
coronavirus alors à la lumière de ce que
vous vous dites une situation compliquée
et pourtant donald trump lui qui
aimerait bien qu'ils souhaiteraient même
si on verra qu'il n'a pas forcément le
pouvoir de le faire mais il souhaiterait
bien en déconfinement dès le 1er mai
faire repartir l'économie quelle est
votre réaction
deux médecins mais dans certaines
régions cela pourrait être possible mais
il faudrait beaucoup d'action au
préalable tout d'abord il faudrait que
le nombre de cas diminue que les
hôpitaux et soit en mesure de traiter
correctement les patients de plus nous
devons pouvoir tester les personnes qui
ont des symptômes au moins sinon la
l'ensemble de la population ou les
personnes susceptibles d'avoir été
exposés
il faut également faire du contact si
nous nous mettions en oeuvre le même
moyen de traçage des contacts que la
chine alors nous aurions plusieurs de
milliers de personnes se rechargeant
cela n'est pas du tout le cas depuis la
récession
nous avons perdu environ 25% de nos
effectifs publics et nous ne sommes
vraiment pas prêt à effectuer le travail
nécessaire à suite à la fin du
confinement
aujourd'hui céline à gander si je vous
comprends bien il vous manque la même
chose qu'en france des masques des tests
est effectivement une politique de
tracking qui est mise en place dans
certains pays comme la corée du sud qui
n'est pas mise également chez vous aux
états unis tout à fait je pense que les
équipements de protection personnelle
le masque de dax et paiera à ce niveau
là je sais s'est améliorée j'ai
effectivement un masque n95 mais on
s'attend à ce que je vis toute la
semaine d'être équipe mais elles sont
encore en situation de pénurie
et s'agissant de tel c'était il ne
s'agit pas que de cela il faut également
avoir des échantillonnages aux naseaux
et sans avoir mis en place de tels tests
elles n'auront pas les échantillons
nécessaires pour tester quelqu'un donc
cela peut poser des problèmes au niveau
de la fin du confinement
qu'en est il des écoles céline aragones
d'air parce qu'en france pour vous
présenter la situation elles sont
fermées depuis un mois elles vont le
rester encore un mois qu'elle est la
politique aux etats-unis sachant qu'on
imagine c'est une question qui est
traitée différemment selon les états
puisque c'est son d etat fédéral mais
quelle est la situation par exemple à
new york sur le front des écoles il y à
des débats entre le gouverneur de l'état
de new york et le maire de la ville de
new york ne sait pas encore ce qu'il va
arriver comme en france nous sommes très
avancés dans l'année scolaire et ne
serait peut-être pas logique
aujourd'hui de réouvrir les écoles un
problème crucial c'est que beaucoup et
enfants les enfants pauvres
recevez des repas gratuits à l'école
notamment par exemple à new york
cela a continué même après la fermeture
des écoles donc pour moi cela est vital
si la fermeture des écoles continue ses
repas devront continuer à être fournis
vous dites c'est vital
si la fermeture des écoles continuent le
médecin qu'en pense-t-il de la
réouverture des écoles en france
certains craignent que les enfants
soient très vecteur du coc vide 19 et le
transmettent évidemment à leurs parents
leurs aînés ce que vous partagez cette
même inquiétude
effectivement je pense que c'est un
sujet de préoccupation même si les
enfants ne développe pas des formes
aussi grave de la maladie selon sans
doute effectivement peuvent-ils porter
la maladie autour de même s'ils sont
asymptomatiques
si en tout cas cela ressemble à la
grippe donc la fermeture des écoles
semble effectivement avoir réduit la
transmission du coc vite un récent
sondage chez nous en france aif a pas
montré que seuls 38 % des français
faisait confiance à notre gouvernement
pour gérer cette crise du coronavirus
qu'on est il aux états unis est ce que
les américains font confiance à donald
trump qui on le sait a commis voilà
certaine prudence en tout cas a pris un
petit peu si vous me permettez cette
expression par dessus la jambe
cette épidémie due qu'aux vie de 19 au
départ les etats-unis sont très polarisé
les gens approuvent ou désapprouvent du
président en fonction de l'appartenance
politique et et non pas sur la base
scientifique qui ce qui est très
problématique car nous devrions
justement nous fondée sur la science
pour déterminer le zapping n'aurait non
pas nous fonder sur notre obédience
politique c'est ce qui est au coeur
justement des discussions autour de la
fin du confinement c'est plutôt
économique que scientifique
merci beaucoup c'est bien au goût de
beurre d'avoir été avec mon dans notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur